thank you very much Dean freed it's a
great honor to be here first of all it's
obvious from the sounds and the audience
out productive you all have been and I
want to congratulate you for being
risk-takers you're all risk-takers and I
think you're taking a risk at a
remarkable time in in our transformed
healthcare rep healthcare effort what
I'd like to do today is to give you what
I personally this is biased but I
personally think is a glimpse into the
future and and what I think is is going
to represent at least the functional
outcome for a huge amount of our health
care provision in health care payment
over the next X 5 to 10 years how that
happens is not necessarily going to be
templated like like we've templated at
geisinger but i think that the
functional outcome is is what you have
to look at we have a particular we have
a particular organizational advantage
and fiduciary advantage in that we have
both payer and provider essentially
working for the same directors and that
allows us to create a sweet spot where
both on the insurance side and on the
provider side we can ask questions about
improving care for various cohorts that
we're responsible for whether they're
hospital-based caregiving cohorts or
whether it's ambulatory care and then
the question is if if there's a way of
reengineering that care and getting to a
more optimal short-term and long-term
outcome is there also a cost advantage
so that's what these three balls mean
basically now we're not as we're not as
closed as Kaiser we're heterogeneous so
we reach out to 25,000 non non employed
non guising our providers we reach out
to 12 hospitals that are not part of the
geisinger system so if we do something
that's very innovative in that core we
can then ask questions about whether it
can be taken out to the much more usual
kind of market where there's not a
direct connection to the total cash
compensation
and the payment incentives for the
providers so it's a very interesting
model we're designed we're in the
boonies basically I'm not sure I'm not
sure you could do this in the city and
it gives us a huge advantage we're we're
in in in in post-industrial and rural
Pennsylvania and we've basically through
a consolidation process in the market
both on the insurance and the provider
side got great market share on both ends
of the of the spectrum and we've
designed our program as a hub-and-spoke
so in order to take care of patients
close to where they live we will admit
them to actually non guising our
hospitals unless they need to come to
one of the hub hospitals for specialty
subspecialty care and obviously the hub
hospitals are very expensive and those
hospitals that are not dealing only in
that high intervention high severity
care are less expensive and less anxiety
prone so it's it's a concept of trying
to be centrifugal and cared getting
patients care for close to where they
live rather than sucking them in to a
very high anxiety high expense hub
unless we have to the entire system
covers about 70 sites a tremendous
number of outpatient sites ranging in
size from one or two docks up to 30 or
40 docks depending upon the population
that that the area serves and it's
completely electronic so this entire
area is electronic with one electronic
health record which is epic so again we
have the information systems on the
payer side on they on the insurance side
and we have one electronic system on the
provider side plus about 12 years ago we
reached out to what now represents 3,000
non geisinger physicians where we've put
portals web-based portals to our
electronic record in their offices so
regardless of whether they are part of
our employed system or not they have
access
and utility for the same electronic
record which is which is an incredibly
important feedback of real-time data if
we're going to change how we care for
patients it's expensive we we spend
about four point four percent of our
annual revenue which this year is
budgeted to be about 3.4 billion 4.4% on
the annual upkeep of our electronic
health record so obviously it has to be
highly utilized and highly effective in
order to justify that but we could not
do what we've done without feedback of
real-time data in a way that's
immediately usable in order to alter how
care is given and in order to see
whether your alterations are actually
having the effect that you want we also
have made a commitment to reach out to
as many of our active patients and have
them connected to us either exclusively
or predominantly electronically moving
away from once every six month off at
visit or once every year office visit or
telephonic connection and we're up to
probably about forty percent thirty to
forty percent of our active patients a
little over two hundred thousand dealing
with us electronically we think that
that's going to be a much better
predicate for getting getting them
really involved in either their health
maintenance or their active care getting
if they have chronic disease this is
some this is the priority set by our
board of directors and when we talk
about quality we're not talking about
checking off a box for the Department of
Health or the joint commission or on the
insurance side for NCQA the National
Quality Association or heat us we're
talking about fundamental reengineering
of care and that is our top priority and
we pay the men and women who are our
full-time doctors up to twenty percent
of their total cash compensation for
achieving goals that are directly
connected to quality and innovation so
up to twenty percent of how we pay them
is not dependent upon seeing more
patients or having increased panel size
or doing more RV use and that's a very
important thing to understand how we've
accomplished what we've accomplished and
here's what we're fighting we believe
that in general we are immersed in
unjustified variation or the care that
we give and a lot of that immersion is
justified by the religion of individual
doctor-patient interaction and we think
a lot of that religion is unjustified so
we have been looking to see how much
variation in caregiving can really be
and really be transformed to devault
default best practice and what effect
will that have on outcome and cost most
systems do not have continuum of care
from primary care to hospital based
specialty to highly specialized care for
for transplant or for cancer care or for
neuro-oncology what have you we have the
entire continuum plus we have the
insurance company so that second dot is
something that we can directly directly
attack you've probably are aware that
most of how we get paid over the last 35
years 40 years has been payment for
performance of a particular unit of work
widget type payment and again because of
the fact we have both an insurance
company IE a payer and a provider we're
able to vary that to look at payment for
getting an acceptable outcome over time
and that's a very very interesting
predicate for a lot of the innovations
that we've we've done and I think up
until recent efforts by by CMS Medicare
and Medicaid administration by the
innovation division of CMS and it's
buried within the ACA up until recently
there have not been incentives to
fundamentally innovate care there are
now incentives question is are they
strategic will we have metrics to
determine
whether they've actually worked or not
so where do we want to be I would I
would suggest that both ethical and and
financial considerations would lead us
to affordable coverage for all I believe
it's ethical to to do that as a nation
but even if you don't buy that there's a
business rationale for affordable
coverage for all I believe we should
move to payment for value I believe we
must insist on coordinated care and
probably the toughest dot of all on this
on this list is continuous improvement
in innovation outside of a formalized
randomized clinical trial which is a
very systematic methodologically pure
way of deciding whether a new treatment
is better than an old treatment we need
to learn from every caregiving episode
that we perform and we have at least at
least theoretically we have the
capability of getting that information
now that we're moving to electronic
electronic aggregation and data
warehousing but we need to create a
sociology where as a system even without
having patients in randomized clinical
trials we can assume that everything we
do will learn from and continue to
improve and we have to incentive goal is
is my own personal fantasy there are
there are two fundamental parts of our
religion one comes from a very
interesting article which for me was
seminal it was written by the rand
corporation Beth McGlinn was the first
author 2003 and what it said was that
about fifty percent of the time the care
that was given as determined by a panel
of experts was either too much too
little or wrong now now let me just
focus on this so we're representing 16
of the economy of the United States in
healthcare and just think even if you
discount that fifty percent figure let's
say it's only thirty percent because
their methodology
quibbles about how they did their study
what if thirty percent of 16 of our
economy was cost without benefit to the
people that we are serving now for me
that's an incredible upside that's an
incredible upside and what we've been
trying to do with our road test is to
see if we can extract as much of that
thirty percent of unhelpful or sometimes
harmful care and will it actually do two
things will it help the quality outcome
and of course will it decrease costs and
for a large amount of our system then we
can decide what do we do how do we
redistribute that captured value so this
is a seminal part of the this is the
underpinning for what we're doing the
second underpinning came from Arnie
millstein's slide here which back in the
90s early 90s I began to a show and
there were other studies that showed the
same thing there was no relationship in
this country when you looked at various
markets between the cost of care and the
quality of the outcome that's what this
slide shows complete chaos complete
random no no relationship at all we have
subsequently moved to believe that
there's actually an inverse relationship
not all the time but most of the time if
you look at the highest cost parts of
our population whether it's Hospital
based treatment cohorts or whether it's
ambulatory cohorts most of the time the
highest cost will relate to the worst
outcome now if you if you buy that if
you if you if you begin to show that
that's true not one hundred percent but
most of the time it takes away this
false polarity between attacking costs
as what's driving you versus helping
human beings because of the same thing
if you can re-engineer care and you can
let's say attack variation and extract
some of that thirty percent which is not
helping patients and maybe hurting them
the question is are you doing two things
are you actually improving their outcome
as well as decreasing costs and in fact
more and more people are coming to
believe that and and we began to see
this in a number of our innovation
experiment road tests starting about six
or seven years ago these are the general
categories of our innovation the first
is is the acute hospital based care that
was redesigned again trying to attack on
justified variation we packaged it as a
single price including us taking
responsibility or treatment of any
complications that would occur within 90
days regardless of their cause we
thought we'd and that that God that was
pretty you know that was pretty
attention capturing for our own men and
women and it also captured a lot of
attention outside that was that was
called the warranty and and the question
was if we looked at hip replacement knee
replacement art surgery cardiology
intervention gastrique restriction for
morbid obesity perinatal the whole nine
month perinatal episode if we looked at
wreath reportin treatment and if we
redesigned it with a default best
practice using either either
evidence-based or consensus from outside
of the institution discipline usually
discipline based or if we just created a
sociology where we looked at at an
inventory of our variation and forced
consensus for best practice for every
step along the way from diagnosis to
rehabilitation number one could we do it
and number two how often could we do it
number three what effect would it have
on outcome and what effect would it have
on cost and as I say we've we've now
spread this out to a huge number of
hospital based interventions and Perry
Hospital treatments we started with
elective heart surgery this was
published in 2006 it's sustainable and
we basically said for every patient who
is getting this care in our hospitals we
would do in the case of heart I think 50
best part
practices for every one of those
patients in real time defining that that
all of the blocking and tackling that
had been looked at in various studies
would be baked in to the entire episode
would be put into our EHR so that we had
real-time feedback not not three months
after the fact chart review but real
time feedback and what we found was we
got a good result before we actually did
this because we started with a good
result I didn't want to take a chance on
a real real bad result getting worse we
started with a good result and we
actually saw improvement so good got
better and this has been sustainable now
over over six years and we saw a
decrease costs so the hospital
contribution margin also increased and
our health plan basically was able to
get a better deal and and part of that
value that was produced had to be passed
back to the buyer so in our area most of
our buyers and commercial are small
companies and they are critically
sensitive to the premiums that that we
offer so that was an interesting start
we've now carried this out to this
portfolio of hospital-associated or
hospital based care and we've
consistently showed we've consistently
showed that that when you do the
re-engineering some of its easier some
of its harder the proven perinatal which
is nine months has about a hundred and
fifty best practice goals that have to
be achieved so it's it's a it's a real
humdinger but we've basically shown that
when you look at metrics of quality for
the proven perinatal you're talking
about c-section rate you're talking
about frequency of missions to the
neonatal ICU you're talking about you
know elective early term
and it's just it's amazing how you get
increased quality as well as decrease
costs and why you know why why should
that be surprising and every other
complex task that has been looked at in
a formal way if you attack unjustified
variation you do two things you increase
quality and you decrease costs now the
push back among the professionals would
be there turning us into robots we are
practicing cookbook medicine but it's
very easy to deal with that if you have
the right process on the right sociology
and that is you basically say to your
men and women you can deviate from this
whenever you want to whenever there's an
individual reason to deviate deviate you
just have to justify it to Europe to
your brothers and sisters and you have
to justify it in in real time and one
acceptable justification is not I was
trained this way 35 years ago and
another unacceptable justification is
I've had a message from God so it's it's
been it's been very interesting the
second issue that that I want to just
review briefly is our approach to take
care of patients with chronic diseases
most of our patients who are in this
particular part of of the country are
older sicker and poorer than just about
any demography outside of the deep cells
the average age of the patients that
we're taking care of is somewhere around
65 to 70 the patients that we started
our version of advanced medical home
with our average age 72 they have for
chronic diseases and they're taking
about 20 pills a day there's they're the
highest utilizing patients the other
patients that come in and out of the
hospital every 30 days and we assumed
that that was a sign number one that we
weren't giving the kind of care that
would be considered optimal and it was
also very high cost so we created an
innovation potential from the community
practice leadership up this is not
top-down the community practice up the
twenty percent of
they're pay twenty percent of how we
reimbursed our men and women would be
based not on panel size not on number of
patients seen but we'd be based on how
whether or not and how quickly they
could get 25,000 of our type 2 diabetic
patients hitting every one of what was
felt to be critical goals or long-term
best outcome for the care of diabetes
and as you can see when we started the
vast majority in fact just a minuscule
number had every one of nine best
practice goals achieved and then over a
period of time by re-engineering the
care looking at the electronic record
what have you a tremendous increase so
that i would say ninety-nine percent of
our type 2 diabetics now have seven
eight or or all nine but seven eight and
nine of these best practice goals
achieved and a number of these goals are
not indicated for instance this level of
a1c which is perfect diabetes control of
its below seven you just don't push that
if you have a patient who's got heart
disease who's over seven so there's
there's contraindications to a number of
these so the question really was what
good would that do and remarkably in six
hundred days of steady state when these
patients were taken care of in this way
there was a significant decrease in the
risk for amputation or myocardial
infarction for stroke and for
retinopathy and and to me that is
remarkable 600 days is not a long period
of time where if you change the kind of
care that's given you're actually
getting a change in the long-term
chronic disease outcome now we haven't
even done the economics on this but you
can bet that when we do the economics on
this you'll see that the cost has also
gone down dramatically for that 25,000
and then the last thing is is art is our
use of data and analytics from
the payer side the insurance companies
do things that the providers will never
do well the providers obviously do huge
numbers of things that the insurance
companies will never do well and our
sweet spot is an attempt to actually
cross that barrier and so one of the
things that we did is we took the
insurance companies data and insurance
company trained and paid nurses and
embedded them in our community practices
in our in our 40 or 45 sites and they
brought the data in to let the doctors
know who were the patients that needed
to have special attention it was
basically concierge care for the sickest
and it was based on not the richest but
concierge care for the sickest and each
nurse had 125 to 150 of the sickest
patients in the given practice and
nothing could happen to those patients
unless it was triaged through that nurse
so that nurse was the general manager of
the patient and the question was would
we successfully benefit those patients
with four or five chronic diseases would
it have an effect on total cost of care
now if you get that twofer it's terrific
for the patient the insurance company
gets a wonderful financial benefit
because total cost of care goes down and
because it's all in the same structure
in the same fiduciary in our system we
can do the internal transfer pricing
getting some of that profit that would
go to the insurance company back to the
people who actually produce the change
and what we found and this has now been
sustainable and it's spread way beyond
those sickest patients we found that
there is about in general about a twenty
percent decrease in admissions per
thousand which is significant we also
found that compared to the expectations
for our cost curve we were looking at at
about about seven percent decrease per
year seven seven percent decrease per
year below our cost curve where we are
now below steady state
now if you recall during the ACA
political run up the questions were
whether we could get one percent out of
our cost escalation over ten years and
this is this is seven percent per year
so I I don't think we're anywhere near
what we could do if any of this is
generalizable so here here are the
caveats most of the immediate effect in
benefiting patients and decreasing costs
is is taken out of the hospital so if
you are a hospital centric organization
you better have a business model to make
up for the fact that you will have an
effect on your volume your volume will
go down so you're either going to have
to build market share by stealing from
others or you're going to have to have a
different relationship to your payer
being paid not on the basis of widgets
produced or units of work done but based
on probably getting some amount of that
total cost of care Delta that has been
created or again you have you have to
backfill the questions that you all will
have to answer I think when you're when
you're out in the real world is any of
this applicable anywhere else outside of
our unusual market are unusual sociology
and our ability because of the market
share in the sociology to do these kinds
of interesting experiments is it
applicable in a fee-for-service setting
in fact our setting is a fee-for-service
setting there was an article on health
affairs last month that basically says
even in a fee-for-service setting this
kind of stuff can be done are we going
to be able to rely on CMS and on the
changes which are built into ACA or
Medicare and on the upcoming changes for
Medicaid as our major partner to incent
and catalyze catalyze this dramatic
transformation of how we view care and
population health and I mean my greatest
worry is not the not the not the
commitment not the intelligence
not the aspirations and the vision of
folks who are working in HHS and CMS my
worry is the the accuracy and the
timeliness of the data the data has to
be fed back almost almost real-time not
quite but it has to be fed back as close
to real time as possible to the
providers in order to change the kind of
care for the patient that's in front of
the provider at a given at a given
moment so i think the market-based
responses here may become even more
important than than than CMS I don't
think I don't think by and large that
November will make a difference in what
I'm saying it may make a difference in
terms of Medicare Advantage and that's
probably a little bit to detail to get
into now but i think that the
fundamentals of the cost trajectory and
the fundamentals of the of the need to
create value here are apparent to
everyone and and it will not be affected
in the intermediate term by the election
and i think the bottom line is we're
going to have much more increasing
demand over the next few years we're
going to be monitoring kind of the
schizophrenic standoff between the
fee-for-service incentives and something
else with whether it's shared savings or
quasi capitation who knows i think i
think the real bottom line here is to
increase value by reengineering the care
and then figuring out how to
redistribute that and i think we'll
probably have either quasi capitation or
that plus fee-for-service with decreased
fees and when i present this to hospital
based organizations i say you do not
want to be the hamster in the hamster
wheel that's a very bad thing with
fee-for-service working harder to
produce more more services and having
those fees go down that's a bad thing so
next steps national costs and quality
metrics absolutely critical and they've
got to be understandable both to the
board of directors of the organizations
that are actually giving the care and
ideally they should be understandable
to the population the population has to
understand where to get their care right
now it's very difficult for regular
human beings who are very bright to
understand whether they should have
their type 2 diabetes taken care of in
system a or system B and we've got to
make that transparency a part a part of
our religion I believe it's quite
possible that not only Massachusetts but
others will have global budgets for
Medicare and commercial and they'll have
to be both Medicare and commercial to
avoid the cost shift Medicare Advantage
depending upon the outcome may or may
not be expanded and focused much more on
quality outcomes for reimbursement
benefit and I think Medicaid managed
care is going to be the answer that most
states move to as we have a 16 million
member expansion of Medicaid over the
next few years that'll be the single
biggest payer expansion over the next
few years and I think we may very well
be looking at price controls which in my
view worked only temporarily if at all
and regulatory commissions we're seeing
both of those things in Massachusetts
which as usual is a forerunner there are
multiple experiments in provider payer
integration models insurance companies
are buying hospitals they're buying
doctor groups dr. groups are buying
other doctor groups hospitals are now
Hospital centric organizations are now
thinking about creating insurance
companies again and this is all in an
attempt to create a different sweet spot
where payers and providers can work
together more or less like like we've
done for our sweet spot and there's a
huge amount of blocking and tackling I
think opportunity in this in this in
this tremendous of ferment and and we're
we're involved in in in some of that
blocking and tackling of trying to
trying to tell people how to do the
Sociology you know the electronic health
record the incentives and what have you
that's all pretty straightforward either
do or you don't do it or you modify it
with the sociology of actually how to
change behavior
on the part of our providers and on the
part of our patients and members if on
the insurance company site is the key
and I think there's a huge opportunity
so let me congratulate you there's
plenty to do I've had the honor of
working with one of the most interesting
organizations over the last 12 years
it's not my work it's their work one of
my directors is here dr. Joel Mendel and
Joel and I will be happy to talk to any
of you who are looking for a job as soon
as we're finished this so
congratulations folks and thank you very
much for the honor of inviting